[Music]
so the best way I can think of - you
know visualize our resilience is we can
think of it like a reservoir or like a
water reservoir you might have a
reservoir that is filled up by different
forms or different streams or different
you know different water sources and
that's very much like where we draw
resilience from we can draw resilience
from our basic level of health and
health related behaviors like you know
how long we sleep how pillow we regulate
our emotions so those are you know
health related behaviors that we are
kind of that gives us a baseline if you
will right so to get our resilience we
also get our resilience from how we cope
with things how our values are what our
thinking about a certain subject matter
is our coping patterns to be
problem-solve do we ruminate so those
are coping strategies that's another
stream that feeds into our resilience
and then finally there's the you know
the greater social structural context
that we're all kind of situated within
so we have universal health care do we
have access to legal and social services
do we feel like we belong in a community
so all of those are kind of like the
different streams that flow into a water
reservoir so when we think of our
resilience we really think about it as a
comprehensive multi-dimensional thing
that gets filled up by different aspects
so for example if we are low on our you
know health behaviors we're not sleeping
as much we can still go and be resilient
by relying on some of the other things
like coping strategies or you know by
relying on our community to provide a
support when we need it
so we kind of think of resilience as
this makeup of all the different things
actually you know contribute to our
resilience and on the other side it gets
drained by different things - right so
we can you know we can have situation
with demands that are kind of unexpected
and you know quite drastic like the
current pandemic that certainly affects
a lot of our resilience we can
something that's a little bit more you
know related to hello we want to throw
right we can think about all the
journeys all the goals that we set
ourselves sometimes they can affect our
resilience and finally you know
sometimes if we have a hard time even
providing food and providing basic
shelter for ourselves that also affects
our overall resilience too so this way
that things fill it up other things will
kind of drain it so the model is a very
dynamic model and kind of understanding
and so the model is that it's the first
time that we've adapted it to the scale
that it has but we've certainly used the
model in previous research that has come
before it we have used the model and the
evaluation measure to capture really
important comprehensive changes in
resilience as a result of you know
engaging in community empowerment and
resilience training we've used the model
to really inform how we understand
mental health and well-being
but I would say that in the context of
the current endemic this is the first
time that a model to its scale has been
adapted and has really highlighted the
dynamic nature of the model
I think the biggest thing to change
about the model and how its adapted with
pandemic is that a lot of times when
when we are not you know utter with the
end we think about our resilience as all
the things that we can source we want to
build our capacity and something like a
pandemic that is so that its effects are
so you know felt you know in all aspects
of our live it really shows our
perspectives on resilience rather than
thinking about our capacity sometimes we
feel like we've got nothing left
like our tank is kind of empty our
reservoir is empty so we shift with a
model instead of focusing on you know
the sources of resilience we want to
really highlight that we all have
resilience and let's look at really
where your resilience needs are not
being met and then we can you know build
capacity that way well first I like to
acknowledge that our team effort in
everything right so including the model
adaptation the live chat certainly a
group effort and getting that off the
ground and especially in such a short
time period I would say that the in in
applying the model and how we understand
resilience the most important thing is
understanding that everyone's needs
might be different so in you know in the
role of a live chat I we really want to
emphasize that the need to understand
the users needs contextualize work
through the beginning of the
conversation to prioritize where are the
things that you know they might come and
and need help with the most whether
that's providing some basic emotional
support providing some information that
can inform their decisions or connecting
them to the right type of services that
they would like to access
ah so we're gonna pee again I think we
all have the idea of resilience right
it's very it's very innate in all of us
we all experience things and we all you
know overcome them because we're all
here so um so for my research I've
always been interested in stress and
resilience how we cope with different
things and the resilience being you know
the the flipside of stress as I
originally had conceptualized it but in
my graduate school career I encounter
some you know challenges and the system
challenges in terms of you know
navigating different resources getting
different support for different things
and when you go through some something
that is challenging it kind of
challenges how your perspective and how
you think of things so I had always
thought you know resilience is something
that is in yourself right you you know
you're either resilient or you're not
and you can either get through things or
you're not and it wasn't until I
experienced some challenges in my
graduate school I realized actually if
it wasn't really for the people around
me you know connecting me with the rice
services me feeling like I had a
community that I belong and that I had
access to you know important things that
I needed
if it weren't for all of that there's no
way I could you know I could overcome or
or even just cope so that really
challenged my beliefs about resilience
and for my doctoral or comprehensive
exam we are asked to each come up with
either either a study idea that is kind
of independent and different than your
your normal line of work or you know
proposed a new motto or theory so I
thought you know what let me go ahead
and look into this resilience literature
let me see what is out there and I find
that a lot of the literature supports my
initial beliefs about resilience right
it's mainly focusing on the person
like a psychological thing so you know
we think about things how we react to
things is very much rooted in ourselves
but we think about you know overcoming
something like the current pandemic it
takes so much more than our individual
will will and our individual health
right we we need to be collective we
need to think about you know what other
factors what what our communities are
doing how we're supporting each other to
overcome the barriers so I really
propose that model published it and
really was well-received so the work
kind of carried on from there so when
did you publish this uh theory or you
were model resilience immortal I
published it back in 2017 beginning of
2017 so it was quite new and originally
I thought I just wanted a publication
you know for your graduate school career
um but it was so well received that you
know we had researchers international
researchers prominent in the field um
you know messaging and asking how's that
work coming along
I found the paper so helpful to to shift
my idea about resilience it actually is
a system approach you know it's
multi-dimensional it talks about the
structural determinants of well-being
talks about things within yourself and
things outside of yourself and how they
interact so really interested in this
work and so many of those increase that
I thought need to pursue this
I think the emotions that a pandemic hun
can kind of trigger vary quite
frequently you know like I go from
states of panic and distress to states
of incredible gratitude and and feeling
supported and and I you know iid able to
say that everyone's emotions are kind of
up and down like this right so um so the
pandemic at an emotional level has
really helped me see things and
understand things and you know and
surprisingly brought on some wealth of
gratitude that that we have a community
that we're building upon that we are
supporting and this community supports
us back you know and and doing something
like that
to support the community is incredibly
fulfilling
so the the model hat continues to
advance Brazilians I think resilience is
such a construct that everyone can
identify with that in some ways you know
lots of expectations at an individual
level about what that might look like so
a challenge is continuing to evolve it
in a way that makes sense to represent
the everyday experience but also
captures it at a you know sophisticated
level that stands up to you know
scientific rigor and scrutiny so that so
next steps for me is to continue to
build that out and and find new avenues
to apply that to certainly continuing
the existing lines of research as well
we have a number of research studies
that are ongoing and that didn't stop
you've been in the in pandemic we just
simply moved everything online on zoom'
it's true yeah and then a long-term goal
continuing to do what I love continuing
to do research knowledge translate teach
work in the community yeah okay thank
you very much thank you Jenny
hope you will thank you bye bye
you